Rangers reported no drownings at Lake
Mead over the Memorial Day weekend but
they did record hundreds of other
incidents and as 8 news now reporter
Ryan Matthey shows us the Park Service
anticipates some of those problems to
continue right through the summer
it looks like the Wiener Dog is a
bestseller well yes floating wiener dogs
water clothes and life jackets the
Kaiser family has sold them all at
boating Lake Mead since 1957. I've seen
a lot of Memorial days out here
but this Memorial Day she says saw more
visitors than at least since the
pandemic a lot of boaters and a lot of
wind yielding a lot of safety concerns
people don't understand especially in
windy days like this weekend that
they're very very dangerous
in total Rangers say they recorded
nearly 450 incidents on these Waters
just over the weekend collisions with
boats arrests but most concerning for
the Park Service pool toys on the water
those are prohibited here at Lake Mead
Krista Johnson chief of staff for the
Lake Mead Recreation Area says over 250
warnings were given several of them for
use of toys not meant for open bodies of
water the U.S consumer product safety
commission recently issuing a fatal
drowning warning for the summer as they
found children ages one to four years
old die unintentionally the most via
drowning the pool toys themselves come
with their own warning label that they
are not approved for open bodies of
water they are called pool toys for a
reason but drunk driving and speeding
citations were also issued the
recreation area reporting 12 arrests and
another 48 citations for the over 50 000
people visiting from Friday to Monday
that's on top of a handful of boating
collisions small fires and calls for
search and rescue
Rangers left with this weekend has a
potential preview of the summer to come
we always anticipate we will need to
remind our visitors you know always get
a designated driver
now here's a breakdown of just some of
the incidents that Ryan was talking
about from this past weekend Rangers did
not elaborate what those 12 arrests were
for but they are expecting more visitors
this summer of course than last year and
considering the water levels are up
slightly and all the launch ramps are
open more people might be heading that
way you can find more on this story as
well as breaking news push alerts inside
of our 8 News Now app it's available for
download on both Google Play and the App
Store